9 millions et demi de cadeaux qu vide
dans le monde et une croissance toujours
exponentielle du virus mais en
martinique l'épidémie est maîtrisée
depuis la fin du confinement la plupart
des cas sont importés
repéré à leur descente d'avion pour la
martinique on a une très très faible
circulation du virus de façon autochtone
locale sos médecins les passages aux
urgences
le réseau des médecins sentinelles de
nous signale plus aucun cas quand on
regarde ce qui se passe en allemagne ce
qui se passe en corée ce qui se passe
dans des états qui étaient les bons
élèves de la gestion du coc vite 19 et
qui sont obligés de confiner qui sont
obligés de revoir leur politique
on doit rester extrêmement prudent pour
que cela dure il faut éviter la
réintroduction du virus à partir du en
juillet un test négatif sera obligatoire
pour prendre l'avion vers la martinique
au départ de l'hexagone ou de la guyane
mais ce n'est pas encore le cas pour
l'instant
et la question des liaisons maritimes et
régionales n'est pas tranchée
c'est à l'étude il sait à l'étude comme
c'est des liaisons internationales avec
le ministère de la santé le ministère du
transport etc
puisque ça oblige autant autant il est
facile d'imposer des sur le dos une
réglementation avec la métropole sur les
liaisons aériennes autant dès qu'on
passe sur les liaisons internationales
c'est du droit internationale s'implique
une réciprocité des échanges mais vous
savez que beaucoup d'états de la caraïbe
impose maintenant la réalisation d'un
test avant l'arrivée sur leur territoire
autre épidémie en pleine croissance
celle-ci la dengue le virus de type 3
circule depuis novembre 2019 1800
personnes ont été testées positives 5800
cas évocateurs sont recensés nous avons
eu au début
essentiellement les communes du sud
notamment sainte luce qui ont été
impactés par par le début de l'épidémie
mais nous constatons qu'au fur et à
mesure cette épidémie elle a évolué
progressivement le territoire du centre
et du nord aujourd'hui sont impactées et
l'ensemble de la martinique qui est
touché par cette épidémie talent avec
5800 cas l'épidémie de dengue pourrait
sembler à première vue plus grave que le
coronavirus mais la dengue a fait deux
morts et le co vide 14 prix or seulement